[Aplausos]
[Música]
américa latina es una de las regiones
más pobres más violentas y para colmo
más azotadas por el coronavirus de todo
el planeta para que os hagáis una idea
se estima que más del 30 por ciento de
todas las muertes por lakovic 19 se han
producido en latinoamérica si lo habéis
escuchado bien a pesar de suponer menos
del 9 por ciento de la población mundial
los datos disponibles apuntan a que
podrían haber sido el epicentro más
castigado por la cob y 19 una de cada
tres víctimas mortales esa es la
estimación en el momento de preparar
este vídeo
y realmente no importa si el resultado
final es una de cada tres una de cada
cuatro o una de cada seis sea como sea
todo apunta a que una vez más también en
esta crisis américa latina se ha llevado
la peor parte la pandemia está golpeando
duramente a américa latina' que es el
epicentro del sufrimiento de la cob y 19
carissa etienne directora de la
organización panamericana de la salud
tal y como os podéis imaginar esta es
una situación que tiene consecuencias
políticas económicas y sociales humanos
renuncia a la miseria en las mayores
protestas en décadas las concentraciones
ampliamente consideradas como
sorprendentes en un país que limita la
disidencia fueron desencadenadas por la
crisis económica agudizada por la
pandemia mucho ánimo desde aquí desde
visual política todos los cubanos que
hartos de tanto oprobio tiranía y
miseria han dicho basta podrán con una
ventosa sentar un golpe de gracia al
régimen castrista mucha fuerza y ánimo
tienen que llegar mejores días para la
perla del caribe tienen que estar al
caer
[Música]
pero el ejemplo de cuba amigos no es ni
mucho menos el único el izquierdista
pedro castillo sin poner un perú partido
en dos el maestro rural que busca
reescribir la historia sea el presidente
del país andino tras un ajustado triunfo
precisamente hablando de perú hace un
tiempo os contamos en visual político
cómo invertir en una mujer peruana podía
ser tan rentable como invertir en el
mismísimo s p500 el índice bursátil más
importante del mundo pero ahora bien
sigue siendo esto así tras la pandemia
cuál ha sido el impacto del coronavirus
en estos entornos y en este tipo tan
particular de inversión sigue teniendo
sentido invertir en una emprendedora
peruana el lugar por ejemplo de la bolsa
norteamericana y quizás la pregunta más
importante de todas qué demonios pueden
hacer los países más ricos para apoyar
que américa latina' de una vez por todas
se ponga en vías de acabar con la
pobreza queridos amigos amigas de visual
político en este vídeo que hemos
preparado gracias a la ayuda de nuestros
amigos de micro os vamos a contar qué
está ocurriendo por qué demonios américa
latina' no despega y por qué el último
plan de joe biden para esta región puede
ser algo así como la historia de un
fracaso anunciado
[Música]
y por cierto para los que aún no la
conozcáis minecraft es una empresa de
impacto social que da microcréditos y
naval a mujeres emprendedoras de
regiones muy pobres en países como
nicaragua perú o méxico una fórmula
amigos que está explotando los últimos
tiempos y que puede llegar a ser muy
pero que muy útil para las comunidades
más pobres vamos a ver la tesis que yo
manejo es que con las nuevas tecnologías
los ahorradores e inversores pueden
invertir en vamos a decir en economía
real no se hace cinco años o diez años
sólo podías invertir en bolsa o si
tenías mucho dinero comprarte una casa
ahora hay muchísimos más instrumentos y
micro auto es uno de ellos lo segundo es
que es lo mismo la tecnología nos
permite una trazabilidad y una
transparencia que no teníamos antes
porque el momento es ahora porque ahora
podemos ser más eficientes que nunca en
la optimización de la inversión y de los
recursos y por tanto generar un impacto
que nunca habíamos podido generar antes
ahora estás a cinco clics de tener un
impacto gigantesco nosotros tenemos
inversores siempre cuento lo mismo pero
tenemos inversores que invierten cinco
mil euros y a los tres meses de repente
han ayudado a 50 señoras y se imaginan
que podrían haber ayudado a 50 señoras y
haber ayudado a generar más de 100
puestos de trabajo
os dejamos el link en la descripción por
si queréis conocer mejor este proyecto y
todo lo que puede ofrecer os amigos
amigas prestad atención porque no creo
que este vídeo os deje indiferentes de
eeuu tiene un plan el coronavirus ha
tenido un impacto enorme en todo el
mundo pero tal y como os podéis imaginar
en los países más pobres sus
consecuencias pueden llegar a ser
muchísimo peores pues lo primero es
entender el contexto en el que viven las
mujeres a las que apoyamos son mujeres
que viven muy al día no tienen ahorros
normalmente o a lo mejor ahorran pero de
forma más líquida o sea se compra una
gallina una vaca para ahorrar entonces
en el momento en el que surgió la
pandemia y no podían salir a realizar
sus actividades económicas se vivieron
una situación en la que es que
literalmente no tenían recursos para
poder comprar comida las cosas muy
básicas
y claro si a la pobreza le añadimos la
criminalidad la violencia y la falta de
oportunidades entonces la cosa empieza a
preocupar a los países más ricos porque
pues porque es el caldo de cultivo
perfecto para la emigración y si
hablamos de américa latina' entonces
hablamos evidentemente de eeuu fijaos el
25 de junio de 2021 detenciones en la
frontera sur de estados unidos superan
el millón en año fiscal 2000 21 al ritmo
actual el total de detenciones en la
frontera para el año fiscal que termina
el 30 de septiembre sería el más alto
desde el 2000 y si hablamos de estados
unidos tradicionalmente hablábamos de
méxico y sobre todo últimamente también
de lo que se conoce como el triángulo
norte esto es guatemala honduras y el
salvador tres países que forman según
los propios datos de naciones unidas uno
de los espacios más pobres corruptos y
peligrosos de todo el mundo pero amigos
ahora eeuu eeuu tiene un plan
y una cama
no no no no no esto sino a esto otro
quiere dar cuatro mil millones de
dólares en ayudas a honduras el salvador
y guatemala para reducir la inmigración
yo bailé en la encomendado a su flamante
vicepresidenta kamala harris que lideró
un plan multimillonario con el que
enfrentar de raíz el problema de la
inmigración ilegal
[Música]
la idea es que si la inmigración tiene
que ver con la pobreza la violencia y la
falta de oportunidades entonces esta
enorme inversión tiene que contribuir a
frenar la por ejemplo se estima que
cuando el pib per cápita de un país
sobrepasa los 8 mil dólares entonces el
interés por emigrar sobre todo a migrar
ilegalmente se reduce sustancialmente
pero claro el problema es que el pib per
cápita de guatemala y el salvador se
sitúa en torno a la mitad a los 4 mil
dólares y en donde aún por debajo en
unos 2500 es decir está muy lejos de ese
umbral de los 8000 dólares de ahí que
badén quiere inyectar un montón de
dinero en la región suena bien verdad
pues amigos espera hace un momento antes
de lanzar las campanas al vuelo porque a
veces las intenciones y los resultados
pues no van de la mano pero para
entender toda esta historia empecemos
por el principio
durante décadas el patrón regular de la
emigración a eeuu pasaba porque fueron
los mexicanos quienes tratarán de cruzar
la frontera en busca de una vida mejor
sin embargo en 2014 se produjo un cambio
de tendencia una avalancha de familias
centroamericanas y niños no acompañados
de esta misma región comenzó a llegar a
la frontera sur de eeuu
y pregunta que pensáis que hizo el
gobierno norteamericano pues en ese
momento a la administración obama se le
encendió la bombilla porque no luchar
contra la inmigración directamente en el
lugar de origen y así fue como nació la
alianza por la prosperidad del triángulo
norte al frente de la cual obama puso al
actual presidente joe biden
la alianza estratégica para la
prosperidad del triángulo norte de
américa central fue el plan propuesto
por la administración de barack obama
para impulsar el desarrollo de la región
centroamericana hasta el 2014 en la
colaboración entre eeuu y estos países
se había dado fundamentalmente en
materia de seguridad a través del plan
mérida ha puesto en marcha por georges
bush primero y más tarde con el cards y
la iniciativa de seguridad regional de
centroamérica puesta en marcha por obama
en 2009 los planes a través de los
cuales y eeuu ha destinado más de mil
millones de dólares para entrenar y
reforzar los cuerpos de seguridad de la
región sin embargo la alianza para la
prosperidad pretendía impulsar no sólo
la seguridad sino también el desarrollo
de estos países
de esta forma hasta 2018 se calcula que
eeuu invirtió en proyectos de desarrollo
seguridad y gobernanza unos 2400
millones de dólares 12 mil 100 millones
en guatemala unos 750 en honduras y casi
500 en el salvador cuando fui
vicepresidente me centre en proporcionar
la ayuda necesaria para abordar estas
causas fundamentales de la migración
ayudo a mantener a la gente en sus
propios países en lugar de obligarla a
marcharse nuestro plan funcionó
joe biden pero no el problema es que no
funcionó tras gastarse miles de millones
las cosas no han mejorado
sustancialmente y desde luego que
queréis que os diga la inmigración sigue
llegando a raudales y por eso la nueva
idea es redoblar esfuerzos y si en el
primer plan se gastaron unos 2.400
millones ahora quieren gastarse casi el
doble funcionará esta vez puede ser este
plan o un esbozo de lo que necesita
américa latina' a gran escala para
escapar de una vez por todas de la
pobreza atentos
[Música]
el pinchado de la ayuda norteamericana
si la lluvia de billetes deliciosa cayó
sobre américa central pero las cosas no
han mejorado mucho ni siquiera del todo
claro que todo ese dinero haya tenido
algún impacto relevante por ejemplo con
el dinero norteamericano se
desarrollaron aplicaciones para que los
campesinos siguieran las cotizaciones de
los productos agrícolas o la forma de
gastar el dinero de los gobiernos
locales en este último programa por
ejemplo se gastaron 30 millones de
dólares que el problema es que muchos
campesinos por no decir la mayoría pues
no tenían smartphones
ni tampoco datos
y se mejoraron las instalaciones de
algunas escuelas pero sin que ello
mejorará en nada la calidad docente de
decenas de miles de campesinos
recibieron charlas sobre cómo mejorar
sus cultivos pero cuando quisieron
buscar financiación para llevar a cabo
los nuevos proyectos les dijeron que el
dinero de eeuu no estaba pensado para
eso se gastaron 20 millones de dólares
en instalar baños en el campo baños que
al poco tiempo los lugareños desmontaron
para venderlos como chatarra
amigos el 80% de los proyectos fueron
encargados a contratistas
estadounidenses contratistas que ni
conocían del todo el terreno ni tenían
ningún incentivo para ahorrar en
burocracia de hecho según muchos
críticos en torno al 50 por ciento del
presupuesto se gasta en administración
salarios dietas y viajes de las propias
empresas contratistas en su negocio los
mismos ejecutores ganan los contratos
una y otra vez a pesar de haber sido
malos ejecutores en el pasado sin
mostrar ningún nivel de impacto y sin
cambiar nada
carlos ponce profesor de gestión
empresarial en la universidad de
columbia ahora bien un momento no
penséis ni por un instante que todas
estas cosas formado particular de la
alianza por la prosperidad para nada lo
cierto es que la inmensa mayor parte de
la ayuda al desarrollo de eeuu y bueno
que casi cualquier otro país tiene
problemas similares por ejemplo la juve
site la agencia de los estados unidos
para el desarrollo internacional es la
agencia del gobierno responsable de
distribuir la mayor parte de la ayuda
gubernamental de eeuu de corte no
militar hablamos de una agencia que
tiene un presupuesto anual agarrados a
la silla de casi 60.000 millones de
dólares pues bien se sabe que muchos
proyectos siendo generosos con la propia
agencia digamos la mitad del total
apenas logran la mitad de los resultados
previstos
siendo también muy pero que muy
generosos porque lo cierto es que uno de
los problemas que tienen todas estas
iniciativas es que es muy complicado
medir los resultados y si no lo puedes
medir pues al final recurren a cosas
como el número de asistentes a una
charla con independencia de si luego
está pues vale para algo o no por
ejemplo dos de los países donde más
dinero ha depositado la ayuda
norteamericana y en general la comunidad
internacional además de américa central
han sido afganistán y haití mejor no
comentemos nada pero desarrollo lo que
es desarrollo pues no mucho este es el
reto amigos a que se enfrenta kamala
harris armar un plan que no suponga
dilapidar cuatro mil millones más en
américa central
[Música]
para colmo algunas investigaciones
apuntan a que la ayuda extranjera en
américa central que es casi inútil a la
hora de impulsar el desarrollo y que
incluso al contrario de lo esperado
pueden aumentar los niveles de
inmigración digamos que los fondos
repartidos financian muchos viajes a
eeuu
en cualquier caso regresando a la
pregunta que nos hacíamos al principio
del vídeo sobre qué pueden hacer los
países ricos para apoyar la lucha contra
la pobreza en américa latina'
quizás tengan otras vías y el
coronavirus ha sido un muy buen ejemplo
en marzo de 2020 empieza el cob y le
empiezan los confinamientos y la primera
pregunta que nos hacemos es qué vamos a
hacer y la solución son un primer fondo
pequeño de créditos de primera necesidad
primera necesidad es una farmacéutica
una mujer que hace reparto a domicilio
de comida
o cualquier médico no entonces esa es la
primera respuesta que le damos y luego a
los meses nos damos cuenta que todo
vuelve muy rápido a la normalidad y que
lo que ocurre es que los créditos han
cambiado un poco el tipo de crédito que
empiezan a pedirnos que las mujeres se
han adaptado a la nueva realidad que hay
amigos los países pobres no necesitan
peces ni tampoco frente a lo que se ha
dicho siempre cañas de pescar lo que
necesitan es financiación para poder
comprarlas y montar luego negocios donde
comercializar los peces y ganas ganas
pues no les faltan
por ejemplo tenemos mujeres que se
dedicaban previamente a temas de moda y
costura y ahora se han puesto a coser
mascarillas porque es lo que claramente
pues la gente estaba comprando ya nadie
se le iba a comprar unos vaqueros
tenemos mujeres que se dieron cuenta que
hoy era el momento de impulsar sus redes
sociales whatsapp facebook se pudieron a
vender como locas por por redes sociales
mejor que gastarse decenas de millones
en apps que no van a ninguna parte sería
mejor por ejemplo armar programas de
financiación participativa en zonas muy
pobres o abrir líneas para apoyar
microcréditos aunque ello supusiera un
menor negocio para las grandes
multinacionales de la ayuda al
desarrollo tampoco estaría mal financiar
el desarrollo de asociaciones y
cooperativas aquí los datos que nos han
pasado nuestros amigos de mi crowd son
reveladores a pesar del coronavirus la
rentabilidad de los proyectos que están
pilotando se ha incrementado no se ha
reducido sino que se ha incrementado es
decir que las ganas por montar negocios
y salir adelante no han desaparecido
sólo hace falta recursos para que se
puedan llevar a cabo
pues la realidad es que en 2021 las
carteras van mejor que nunca
sí que es verdad que uno de los seis
países en donde estamos trabajando está
funcionando peor que es perú porque la
verdad que ha sufrido mucho mucho el
confinamiento pero donde estamos pues
las carteras van mejor que nunca
deseando dar más créditos que nunca
porque es más necesario que nunca
en fin queríamos insistir una vez más
con este enfoque porque que queréis que
os diga me parece muy revelador que mal
se hacen algunas cosas cuando se dispara
con el dinero de todos que hay mal para
todos es muy fácil hablar de ayuda al
desarrollo pero muy difícil poner
resultados sobre la mesa pero llegados
hasta aquí turno para ti crees que el
nuevo plan de yo by the end y kamala
harris funcionará aprenderán de los
errores pasados o seguirán dilapidando
cientos y cientos de millones dólares en
países que cada vez están peor déjanos
tus impresiones por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]